Good morning, folks.
Any queries, questions, clarifications,
please put them in the chat box.
I call this 0R because we start the
session here.
And when we start the session,
I'd like to have all my queries and
problems listed so that we can proceed
with the subject matter.
We discussed.
So.
Okay, how many questions will be there?
I'll have to check up how many questions
will be there.
Ohh.
Hi, Renuka, I'd like to hear your voice.
Good morning, sir. So,
I was just checking out how many
Good morning, right? Yeah.
questions would be coming for the exam,
whether...
Yeah, no, I've got a question to ask.
If a question has got parts A, B,
C or something,
would you call that a separate questions
or one question?
One question, sir.
one question.
Then I think there'll be probably three
or four questions,
but there'll be parts and those parts
might be fairly disjointed.
They may be on different topics,
maybe related, maybe unrelated.
Could be on similar topics,
but how will that help in any way?
Yeah.
I wonder,
getting psychologically ready for the...
Whoa, sort of.
Nothing, I just was just wondering,
because often we see a lot of subjects
Yeah, okay, yeah.
having like multiple kind of like
question paper patterns,
so just wondering.
Yeah,
it's a long time since I paid for an exam,
but the thumb rule I would go by is just
divide the time available by the marks
and try to distribute a time evenly.
And say, let me say it's a 1 1/2 paper,
and there just happened to be 3 questions.
There may be 4. If there are three,
I'm taking it for simplicity, 30 minutes.
Okay. Now you find that question has got..
.
This is a 30 mark exam, if I'm right,
and my learning facilitator,
Professor Utpal Mukhupad there,
he's a very, very senior faculty,
like he's been in senior positions in the
IT industry, and he...
He plays a major role in evaluation. Okay.
So it's actually with him,
I've been teaching with him for the last
10, 15 years. So I know him fairly well.
Now,
what happens is that say in that five
marks,
he has distributed a given question to
two parts, which means 5 marks each.
You give 15 minutes to the question.
And my
Suggestion to students is,
don't be in a hurry to dump your brain
onto the paper.
I would suggest the 1st 5 minutes,
read it very carefully,
Yes.
because English is a very bad language.
It's very deceptive. And sometimes,
you know,
it may be difficult to understand.
What the question is looking for?
You will be an expert in architecture.
You may have architected the...
for all we know.
But then in an examination scenario,
the target is not how great an architect
you are.
It's just a question of how you approach
that particular paper.
And as per the expectation of the person
who's going to evaluate,
and that's a very weak thing.
But that happens in real life also.
You have to meet up the expectation of a
client.
The client is not clear about the
requirement.
Client probably doesn't know the
Yeah.
requirement. And when you deliver,
then the client discovers that this is
not what is required.
And you get bad marks, not the client.
And the same happens in an exam.
All you can do is try to understand the
requirements as well as you can and hope
that what you understand of the
requirement is what the customer actually
wanted as a requirement.
That part of it continues to be luck,
irrespective of the age of AI and
whatever else.
I thought I'd just have a chat with you
to express my area.
Yes, sir.
So go through all the slides.
That's the best you can do.
There's nothing else you can really do
about it. But now, for example,
Yes, sir.
the topic I'm taking today.
Ohh.
Ink color, blue or black?
I can just give you my choice.
I prefer blue,
but I use a lot of black these days.
I don't know why most of the...
roller pens and everything in the market,
they seem to be selling black.
And when I was in school,
I used to use turquoise.
I just we used to use a fountain pen in
those days, and it helped me stand out,
so...
And, uh, you know, if you,
if you sign a legal document in Bengal.
There's a particular color,
it's either blue or black.
And when you go and sign a legal document
in Punjab, it's the other way around.
So this was, this story is 10,
15 years back.
I don't know whether now they've become
more liberal.
The legal people seem to be very,
much more
uptight than us IT people, you know,
we change with the time.
People go with it in shorts too.
Digital sign, all right. Digital sign,
they want your photograph,
they want all your fingers out there.
And yeah, the material is printed.
And after taking all your 10 paws on the
electronic pad and taking your photograph
and in a group if possible,
they still want you to sign something.
But, well, that's it. It's good.
Things have improved A lot. Yeah.
Situation Learning Assignment.
I cannot promise really this is something
which is outside my control.
But, uh...
The attempt is normally to give it to you
before assignment 2 starts. Okay.
And.
You know,
you need to have the least anxiety about
the scores and quizzes and assignments
because...
By and large, the schools are liberal.
I really pity a few people who landed up
uploading the assignment for the wrong
subject.
There are some people who tried to upload
in the last minute.
It was going to be midnight.
They hoped the system would be faster,
but...
It hit 1159 before they could upload.
And my request always has been that try
to do whatever you want to do before the
last contact session before closing.
Yeah, it goes. It goes. I mean, that's it.
In fact,
I still remember my son did this course
around 10 years back.
And he used to work for an IT company.
He still works in IT,
but for a non-IT company now.
So he had the same problem. And you know,
some faculty are very sweet. You know,
they'll accommodate, they'll help you,
they'll extend the time.
There's some faculty like me who are very
uptight about it.
this thing.
I don't want to be unfair with the people
who've submitted on time and don't want
to interfere with everything and I don't
have an infrastructure who will take care
of.
all this sort of stuff. Well,
even he did not get an extension and he
lost the first, after that he was careful.
He, thereafter,
he never tried to upload two years this
MTech program that you are doing.
That was the last time we tried to upload
on the last day.
So that's it.
You got to keep 24 hours in hand.
After all,
you treat right from the first day to the
last day,
you treat them as 10 makeup exams.
So the earlier the better.
If you do it a little later,
you get more time to study,
you can attend the latest contact
sessions. But then...
It's better to finish it off.
Don't wait for that. Amitabu,
I hope you are not one of the people who
missed it.
I mean, thank God. Thank God.
Another trick I tell people, you know,
No, sir, I have submitted.
I was able to submit.
I don't know whether it works or not.
You put it there.
I think there's an option to put it in
draft.
You know,
and my request to even Professor is that
if somebody has got it in draft,
give him a small penalty, but evaluate it.
So.
Well before the time,
if there's a provision to save it as a
draft, do that.
At least you don't get completely
disqualified.
I'm not sure.
Can anybody confirm whether that option
is there to save it as a draft?
Yes, sir. Yeah, yeah,
it is there to save it as a draft. Yeah,
Yeah, it is.
so but but I honestly it is a little
confusing because unless you read it
Okay, great.
Good aec.
properly,
it doesn't say that whether it's
submitted or not.
OK, so anyway,
if you if somebody has left it as a draft,
let me assure you it will not be ignored,
but minor penalty will be there.
So.
That is decent.
Thank God, sir. Actually, my submission,
I did it on 4th for a 7th, but it was,
I realized it is in draft.
Okay.
Oh, okay. Okay. No, no, no.
I won't be considering.
If you consider, then the thanks for the.
The faculty concern will consider,
but it will definitely be considering.
I've sent a mail already.
No mail, nobody would look at. You know,
that's why I keep telling the students,
if you give a mail,
try to talk to me in zero hours.
Tell me about your mail and let's attend
to it.
Two reasons.
One is you are sure that it has been
heard.
The second reason is that the reply goes
to everybody because there are lots of
people who don't ask,
they need to get the answer.
So in this particular course,
if there is a variation with other
subjects, don't apply it here,
we'll be absolutely upright about.
the target dates.
It's closure means closure.
There are people who miss the first one
or two quizzes.
My standard answers to them is that
they'll have at least 13,
maybe 14 quizzes.
If the examination department allows.
an extra week.
So that they need to consolidate the
marks and all that.
So they put a deadline that by this date,
all EC1 evaluation has got to be
completed. If they give extra time,
I'll give even the 15th quiz. And.
Best 8 is just, because if you get 8,
the variation of mark with people who
have just appeared for eight and people
who have taken the best eight is not very
big. It's not a big variation,
because people who are appearing are
normally getting good scores.
My main objective in appearing for this
quiz is...
that it is a pretext for a quick review
on the subject matter.
Absolutely nothing else. And...
It's my belief that if you've given a
little bit of time in this course,
considering the background my students
come from,
you all are not coming from scratch,
straight out of college,
or a group of people who have just
appeared for a multiple choice exam and
learned how to crack it and gotten.
So the crowd I'm working with,
each one of you is a person that a
corporate found good enough to employ and
pay a good salary to.
So with such a crowd,
I don't have to be worried about whether
you are capable of learning or not or
whether you can keep.
My biggest problem is that almost all of
you
do not have the time to devote to this
course that you have registered for.
So if somehow you can be encouraged to
put in a little bit of time in this
course,
is going to do you a lot of good
professionally. That's all my thing is.
Type your answer in keyboard or upload
diagrams in a pen paper. Say,
if you are very good in engineering
graphics, you draw beautiful diagrams.
Some of handwritten diagrams do help to
create an impression,
but there's no mandate of that kind,
Pratyesh. There's no mandate.
You can do a.
But definitely be very careful that the
dash sketch diagram of ChatGPT,
don't try to submit it.
It just gives away.
So use all the AI tools,
but don't let it be so expressive that
what you've delivered is just come
straight out of.
And here, tool and got dumped.
And yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, so sorry to interrupt.
So I'm actually talking about the exam.
So in the exam,
can we type our answers on the keyboard
for the same question and let's say,
but there's a diagram. Yeah.
Well, yeah, see,
this is a question you should clarify
with the examination department.
But I can tell you out of my experience
Okay.
from evaluation,
you can give part of the answer typed and
part of the answer scanned.
It has been that from in the past.
So what normally people do is wherever
Okay.
there's a sketch,
they draw it on paper and scan it.
The rest of it, they type out.
Okay, sir.
Because particularly for the more
experienced people,
people who've been working for the last
10 years,
most of us have forgotten how to write.
I have. Okay, so typing is good.
Exactly.
Even I don't have that much experience,
but I feel like I forgot and I love to
overwrite and everything,
so typing feels safer for that.
Then you're then you're a quick learner.
Quick learners forget also quickly. So,
The.
OK, so, OK,
so that's Sampal is telling you the last
exam experience.
I'm also telling you the last exam
experience. So we are in the same boat.
You know,
these questions are best answered.
People try to answer questions on behalf
of others and they make a mess of it.
So I will not try to tread on feet of...
There's an instruction department,
examination department. See,
many people complain about the helpline.
Helpline are people who are supposed to,
they're the first point of contact.
They try to forward it somewhere.
And when they know nowhere else to
forward,
they try to forward it to the faculty.
And
More often than not,
the faculty is either helpless or does
not want to give an answer which you
would like to hear.
So they avoid answering.
So I'd like you to answer it straight out
question,
ask the question out here so that I'm
forced to answer it, whatever answer,
like I've hardly answered your question.
But...
Sometimes, you know, see, SNEHA here,
for example, answered one question,
whether you can save it in draft.
So if it does work for assignment one,
it's going to work for assignment two.
So just go ahead, within two, three days,
whatever is ready,
put it over there in draft.
What will happen? Worst comes to worse.
Instead of draft,
it will become a final submission.
You wouldn't have missed it.
And have at least something ready before
you put it up in draft.
Maybe you intend to polish it up,
but it's after all just five marks.
So what you...
You know, you have this marginal utility.
First mark is very easy to score.
Second is also easy.
Third is a little more difficult.
Fourth mark is extremely difficult.
Fifth mark,
sometimes teachers simply don't want to
give it.
That's the feeling I have about it.
Not that I don't feel like giving it.
I feel happy with an answer. Generally,
I'll give a 5. But
People like to keep their five marks or
something that is absolutely exclusive,
that impresses them out of the way.
So if you have done something worth three
marks or four marks,
it's not a bad deal unless you're looking
to be in an idol or something like that.
And professional coaches.
One should try to max them,
try to learn enough.
Okay.
So let's, now that we've done with this,
my good wishes for the upcoming exam and
you're taking the regular or the makeup.
favorite question is which is easier,
makeup or regular?
I would not like to comment on that.
When I was a student half a century ago,
the regular exam was definitely easier.
So some very old-fashioned teacher would
try to make it more difficult,
but now is we don't try to really create
2 papers and then we shuffle the
questions around and put it.
Only thing I'd like to warn everybody
There's a fairly wide coverage of the
syllabus.
This is something I have to check up.
I'll have to see my calendar.
PRAJJWAL,
I request you also to look up the
calendar.
Don't depend on anything we talk here.
Okay.
I suppose you're right,
but see the calendar.
The.
I normally jot down the calendar.
Yeah.
12th and 26th, no class,
19th day is a class, okay.
Yeah.
I think there is a class, okay.
OK, Naveen.
19th.
I have to check up my calendar.
I may have to adjust that class,
let me see.
If I have to adjust the class on the 19th,
I'll inform you well in advance. Okay?
So just look out for any announcement on
Ms. TEAMS and in Taxila announcements.
Yeah.
Excuse me, sir, but 19th is cancelled.
It is coming cancelled.
Oh, I'm so happy if it is cancelled.
Why is it cancelled?
19th we have exam.
19.
You mean 19 September?
19th September.
Okay, okay, okay, yeah, 9.
And next week to that also it is
cancelled.
Next Saturday. Next Saturday. Okay,
next Saturday is the 19th. Okay. Oh,
Yeah, next Saturday.
good for me. So 19th. Oh, fantastic.
I'm going to be traveling during this
And 26 is also cancelled because of phone
makeup.
period, both the days. So good for me.
Thanks a lot. Yeah, I've seen that. Oh,
that's a different class.
Uh...
Okay.
That is on.
IT infrastructure. Okay.
The class of 19th is an IT infrastructure.
Okay. I didn't look up the title.
K.
Good, good for me. Thank you. Thank you.
OK.
Next Saturday was 19th,
I didn't take note of that.
Okay, let's move.
Conformance testing and reconstruction.
These are words which we need to
understand.
Conformance means there's a decision.
There's a rule.
Weather.
We are doing as per what we decided or as
per the rule that is conformance.
Testing is verification and validation
are called testing.
So we confirm whether we are conforming
or we are not conforming.
And if we find we are not conforming,
then the steering is in our hand,
we get back into.
Attract and drive a little carefully.
Reconstruction.
If I'm trying to define it right at the
beginning of the class,
before people divert off or lose track.
In spite of my warning again and again,
if there's a question in the exam,
50% of the people write a long lecture on
the wrong stuff.
People somehow believe that
reconstruction is...
Designing a new architecture based on an
old architecture. It is not that.
If there's a question of reconstruction,
people will say that, okay,
when you do a new architecture,
you've got to make sure of this,
you have to make sure of this.
This is how you reconstruct an
architecture.
And they use the word reconstruct,
but they are talking about modification
of an architecture,
reconstruction of architecture.
is determination of what the architecture
is, documenting it,
presenting views of an architecture,
of a system that already exists.
Please understand them very, very clearly.
That is what when you're asked to do an
architectural reconstruction,
you're supposed to study the system with
whatever is available with you.
Maybe you're having the source code,
maybe it is running,
maybe there are people who are aware of
the infrastructure,
that people know how to operate it.
Whatever knowledge you can collect.
Based on that,
you will document the architecture.
You will draw views of the architecture.
With or without the details being
available.
Because architecture.
Is always there.
It may or may not be documented.
It may or may not be good from the point
of view of the beholder.
The company owning the system may believe
it is not a good architecture.
The people using the architecture may not
believe it's a good architecture.
The architect who's now looking at the
architecture may not believe it is good,
but it is there.
You cannot say there's no architecture.
Next.
An architectural document may not be
available.
The architecture may not have ever been
presented to anyone.
The architecture may not have been
recorded.
No written views may be available.
Nobody operating the system may be aware
of the architecture, even that's possible.
But there is an architecture.
your job, for whatever reason may be,
to reconstruct it. More often than not,
you need to reinstruct an architecture
because there's a problem in the system,
you wish to modify it.
and putting in your hand into the oven
without knowing whether it's off or on
can burn your fingers.
So you don't go around touching a running
system unless you become aware of it.
So just to open it after this, now,
if you go away, at least the biggest...
reason for problems is done with,
you know the meaning of these words.
Once.
An architecture is in place, you know,
very,
very senior people get involved with a
project.
When a project is initiated.
And you have a.
A project running.
And the development starts.
These biggies,
they get busy with other things.
Maybe picking up another project,
trying to understand something else.
And they have so much of feet.
in the team,
then they believe that the project will
be in control.
No,
they forget the fact that you have some.
genius qualities in designers.
And the designer is the guy who's in the
frontline in the war.
He really believes that he's got all the
guns and everything and he's going to
shoot the enemy down.
That type of attitude and absolute
self-confidence.
And it's human nature to think.
The decisions taken.
Which are placing a constant in you?
Must have been taken by accident.
Probably the person didn't realize that.
I'm studying the system in detail.
I realized that person probably didn't
realize and has taken this decision.
Let's make the change. We'll inform later.
And I have been subject to that for a
long time because by my good fortune,
from the day go,
We were in senior positions because there
were there were no juniors in this line,
so even the people who started learning
ABCs, we were the...
Ultimate authorities, big guys,
like you joined a company and you had the
board of directors.
In those days they were all 50 plus and
you had one young 20 year old and that
was you.
So you always got to handle things.
From a very young age,
I think because there were no seniors who
were aware of these technologies,
and those who were for administrative
heads,
so maybe a person who's done accounts all
their life is made head of IT for the
company, but...
We were determining the stuff, so...
Normally, people like this,
and even we people did it.
A boss with 30 years of experience
handling finance tells you something as
this for an old man, what does he know?
So we did some check only to find out
later that
We are having to redo things.
Because the boss is the boss.
He tells you,
I'll ask you to do it that way.
You better have done it.
But.
Sometimes these people actually have a
problem and they are in a hurry to meet
deadlines, they make changes.
Sometimes it so happens,
they have not understand that, stood,
they have not understood the intricate
language used by the architect.
The beautiful diagram is drawn.
And because of a misunderstanding,
Stree away. It's like the sheep, you know,
the shepherd.
puts all the sheep on a hillock,
and one or two of the sheep will stray
away.
The same problem depends on which country
you've been reading your books from.
If it is Scotland, it is sheep.
If it is the Americas,
it is talking about cowboys handling
cowards. There's a lot of cowards with...
on horseback, trying to make sure the...
animals stay within control.
So it's a similar situation.
The architect has to assure conformity,
has to assure that in the process of
trying to good or in the process of not
understanding.
Architectures is not confirmed.
We call this drift.
The architecture drifts away,
just like the wind blows away the clouds,
the trips.
What are the type of trips?
The architect had said that these will be
the layers.
And each layer will call.
Goa.
Layer just below,
and then this fellow says...
I've got layer one, layer two,
layer three; let me put it down.
I've got layer one.
Layer 2, layer 3.
I want to access certain data,
so I ask layer two. Layer 2 does nothing,
immediately asks layer three and picks up
the data.
Passes it to layer two,
layer 2 responds to layer one,
layer one gets the data, presents it.
It was a silly requirement.
And you wanted to quickly deliver.
That's the thing.
There is a quick requirement, and just...
In one instance,
this person folding layer one makes a
call directly to layer three,
picks up the data,
and finishes the project.
I know it's trivial.
I'll set it right later.
I will set it right later.
Write later.
This has got a very nice term for this
setting it right later.
It's called technical.
Will somebody give me the word?
Get.
Ah, absolutely. Great. Thank you. So...
DEEPAK.
And we create a lot of these technical
debts, you know.
And then we don't ever get the time to
repay these debts and these things stay
in the system.
So you got to make sure these things
don't happen.
Very often there are things which we try
to do quickly.
You'll find people who are not very
experienced, you ask them to do anything,
it's not tomorrow.
That tomorrow doesn't seem to come.
Somebody who sees it knows the job.
You ask a requirement? Is it a thought?
It'll take a month.
With all your seniority is going to take
a month,
that fellow is going to do it in one day.
My normal answer would be,
let that person do it by tomorrow.
It doesn't matter.
If it's not that tomorrow, give it to me.
I'll give it to you in a month.
So that's how it happens,
because if something is going to require
a month, it's going to require a month.
That's what was saying a day because the
person doesn't know what is supposed to
be done.
So,
I'm giving an extreme example just to
prove a point.
It may not be exactly like that, but...
What really happens is that shortcuts do
get taken.
I've given an example where it is
deliberate,
that times when you simply don't
understand,
you have not understood very clearly what
it might be.
So.
that we talked about.
So this was the data access layer.
And this is the database.
So, this is maybe the business layer.
No.
You say all these layers use certain
services.
Whatever the service may be.
Maybe.
Using.
Log4j baby.
GUDIYA has just been allowed in.
Normally if you log in with a bits ID,
you will not be made to wait in the
waiting room.
So always a good idea to use the bits ID
to log in.
Yeah,
people who are working in corporates have
got dual IDs. Yeah,
you have dual IDs on your...
I also run into that problem sometimes.
So you don't realize which ID you are
currently logged in with.
Okay, okay, I got it. Got it. No,
I understood must be something like that.
So, okay, so...
Publish subscribe model,
those of you who are not.
Groomed into IT.
With not had a semi IT background,
a publish, subscribe.
Model.
Just quickly coming to it.
You have a publisher.
Which handles the data?
So all the data is organized and stored
with the publisher.
So publisher could be a subsystem,
it could be a class,
depending on at what level you are
looking at as architecture,
it might be a subsystem.
It could be an entire RDBMS for all you
know.
And if you're looking at it as a
programmer.
You may have the publish class,
and you may have the subscribe class. Now,
the publish class also has the capacity
to enlist subscribers,
so it could be a database containing the
subscribers, it could be a class,
a collection of subscribers maintained.
As.
Oh, an object within an object.
Now,
whenever there's material which is to be
shared with subscribers,
the subscribers also have the preferences,
what type of items they want to subscribe
for.
The publisher informs all subscribers
based on the link that the subscribers
have provided.
In an object-oriented program,
it could be a call,
a method available with the subscriber.
In the case of a larger system,
it could be notifications,
it could be an API call,
any type of method of communication.
So it communicates to the subscriber that,
yes, I've got new data.
And the subscriber automatically responds
to that call by making a call according
to the way the subscriber requires the
data.
The subscriber gets to the publisher,
pulls...
the data. So it's not a push module,
it's a pull module.
Skype subscriber pulls data,
only the intimation is pushed to the
subscriber.
The subscriber is only intimated by the
publisher. I've got news and when you say,
oh, you got news and might have said, no,
I only want to have sports news.
says news means must be sports news and
the subscriber knows exactly how to pick
it up and picks it up.
In Log4j,
you've got a protocol where you can store
the priority of message, the type of data,
the variable, the value.
It's an open source tool which allows you
to keep logs.
And very often logs are maintained for
the purpose of debugging.
for the purpose of improvement, control,
for whatever purpose logs may maintain.
If the company has taken a decision that
we are going to maintain this model
across the system,
Some wise guy thinks that, okay,
I'm writing this program.
In my cache blog, I will open,
I'll insert data into a data table,
and it's going to be available in SQL.
It's good enough for my use.
You have deviated from the architecture.
So this type of divisions do take place.
Maybe good intention, maybe accidentally,
maybe.
It's your nature to be a little
innovative.
And then there's no point arguing that
you are doing it better than the system.
When you are in a system,
you follow the system.
Like if I'm teaching with bits and bits
has got a lot of methods for doing things.
If an instruction comes,
we follow the instruction.
We don't take on the role of telling bits
how they should run their business.
There are occasions when they give an
opportunity to provide feedback,
one provides a feedback.
Whether it is listened to or not is not
dependent on whether somebody wants to
listen or not.
It depends on how well I put it across.
So if my feedback is not...
Which slide is being shared? OK,
I will just show you. OK,
I've taken you to the right slide.
Have you, has it come to you?
Balakrishna.
Sir, is it slide number three now?
Yeah, three.
I forced everybody to do three just now.
Okay, understand, yeah, yeah.
I forced everybody to do three.
Okay, sir.
So, yeah, there's a button.
which if you click private view,
everybody's forced to come into that
slide. And when I open it up,
now you can again drift. So over here,
I find it better to allow people to drift
because you are sitting through two hours.
You may not be very interested in
listening to me all the time.
So you can go and look at the remaining
slides.
Okay, sir. Thank you.
I was thinking some issue with internet
Yeah, I'm good.
or something.
No, no, no, no.
Actually,
I normally land up covering a lot of
things in future slides while sitting on
one slide.
I don't like the idea of reading a slide.
It bores me and I believe it might be
boring other people because if people
want to read slides,
there are lots of tools available.
They'll just put the slide thing and
they'll probably get a better accent than
me. You can.
Hear it from a Ferengi, OK?
So if you have some sort of a mechanism,
any mechanism that is in logging,
I've talked about Log4G over here,
not using it and using your own stuff.
Is any?
Welcome some chat in the chat site about
your experience with architectural drift.
Any of you,
many of you all have got enough
experience to be teaching over here,
so let's have some.
Examples of drift and how you managed it.
OK, take your time.
When I get the example,
we'll come back to it.
Coding style state why you've done code
in a certain way,
so when you state it in the code.
people particularly who are modifying the
code.
They will know.
That see,
this is because of the architects
requirement,
so I'm not supposed to fiddle around with
it.
That today.
Lots of programming.
Is done using frameworks.
Microsoft presentation format,
communication foundation.
Microsoft Communication Foundation,
you know they.
There is a lot of ready-made code.
which not only make sure that you conform
to a decision,
also make sure that you are not
overloaded with a lot of extra work in
trying to achieve things that are obvious.
For example, security.
So framework comes up with updates and
making sure that it's in conformity with
the previous.
framework,
it tries to give you better and better
facilities.
But you stick to certain architectural
standards.
And if you're interested,
you can go through the...
reference given for Microsoft, for Amazon.
You can see some of the data over there.
Then you can use code templates.
In fact.
If you are working on a small project and
you're writing a small bit of code.
If you just give your code to any AI
module,
it's a good way to get some white box
testing done.
You just said, okay,
please go through this code and give me
suggestions for improvements.
And if you think there's something wrong
with my coding style, let me know.
Or just please be sure it is properly
indented.
These little things,
the tools are available now, you know.
Earlier, when I had a list of numbers.
And I want to write an SQL query with
these numbers.
Converting this into commas,
I used to use a formula in Excel and get
it.
But with the tools available today,
it's become so easy.
I simply approach this number into an EA
module and tell them,
please give me this list in comma
separators. OK, beautiful.
And I copy it into my PLSQL and file my
query. So.
Things.
So these AI modules,
they all use code templates.
So if sometimes I want to write a
particular type of code, small code,
I want to just go through a cursor in SQL.
So rather than type the code, I just ask,
please give me a template for running a
read-only cursor.
It gives me the read-only cursor.
I have to make minor changes here and
there,
put in the code according in the correct
thing.
So these make sure that your code is
properly structured.
You are not fooling around,
you don't devote things.
You don't leave out the try-catch finally
blocks,
so all these templates will automatically
have that,
and the beauty with the new IDE is that
they even suggestions for the code if you.
Abhishek Sharma Sikan.
Then.
Update architecture document.
If you need to review something,
Just around.
if you think you've got some good ideas.
Then...
Ohh, this year.
Ohh.
Ram Ram.
Just your.
Okay, we'll just say Jaishi,
unmute everybody and continue. Okay,
Almandir Viswanathan.
thank you.
Yeah.
When somebody says something so good,
so nice, as to say, Jaish,
the least you can do is reciprocate,
but then...
I keep warning people that sometimes
these moments can be as sad as a wardrobe
malfunction.
And just a statutory warning I'll give
you. I've allowed even cameras on, okay,
so be very careful.
Audio malfunction may not be as dangerous.
Make sure you don't have an accidental
camera switching on. Okay.
Good.
We talked about it architecturally
evident coding style.
If they would indicate the layer in the
code.
If you're using publisher, subscriber,
I've described what it is,
indicate in the code that it is a
publisher.
And you can even mention what is the
nature of subscriber,
what are the requirements.
If you're using message queues for
communication between components,
indicate that the component is doing
insert messages.
Some of you might be using the Amazon
communication.
Kit that is available.
So indicate very clearly that this is the
architectural decision.
All messages are being are using this
service from Amazon, hence used.
And write down the structure properly,
define the variables,
explain what they are.
So just make sure that even other people
who work on it after you,
They realize why that has been done.
They don't try to...
It's human nature to try to improve
things, but in trying to improve things,
you can create problems.
I have personally had problems when
things used to be more liberal.
Certainly, we are maintaining a code.
We find that the fellow has picked up a
DLL from God knows where and put it into
the code.
And in a small organization,
very often we don't, and in the old 30s,
dependency checking was not done. Today,
under security verification,
it will come up.
So when you run a vulnerability test,
it will expose any third party.
The tools or APIs or...
DLLs that come in.
These are very PUPPALA.
automated open source systems, auto star,
hibernate,
anybody working with Java would have used
a lot of.
This, so these, of course,
you cannot forget our.NET frameworks;
they really,
if you are working on Microsoft.
Most of the job is done by the framework
for you. And that's an increasing trend.
Gradually.
programming the way we've known
programming through a life lifetime
doesn't exist.
There was a time you wanted to do things,
you had to get out to a similar language.
Today, the frameworks.
get updated,
you get patches for the framework,
and things carry on.
This is a.
Model View Controller Framework.
Very similar to publisher subscriber.
The data is stored by the model.
There we had it with the publisher.
Every view is a subscriber,
but in a model view controller.
There's a controller that comes in.
So.
When there are too many people in a
department.
You have to appoint somebody as the lead.
So, the lead is done,
neither the model nor the view,
but it coordinates the activity between
the view and the models.
So.
The controller.
It's very often a facade which is
connected by the user interface.
The user interface accesses the
controller.
The controller sends all updates to the
models and informs the view,
sometimes something the model may inform.
But in the classic thing,
it'll inform the view, let's see,
there's an update.
The view may also.
There could be user action which can be
triggered from the view and the user
interfaces.
have a lot of triggers and
Any fetch?
For the data is normally there in the.
Of the controller.
Gets the data from the model.
This model can directly provide data to
views.
So, whenever there is an update.
Model.
Can either directly inform the view,
because these,
when it directly informs a view, it is a.
It's not an active view. There are some...
Use, for example,
in an industrial situation,
you might have display boards all over
the factory.
So they may not have a controller
attached with them.
So model informs the view,
view which is the data and shows it
directly on the screen.
So, these type of...
One thing to be remembered, all these...
patterns that we have.
When we use them in practice,
we don't use them exactly in the vanilla.
Of that.
You make variations.
Are there any examples that have come up?
Okay.
Yeah, when we we put it,
I allow private view,
it doesn't change automatically,
so I think once in a while if I...
Do this little help, but then it,
unless they pull people away from.
What they are doing?
A template, see, look at it.
It gives a structure.
So code coding in more systematic people,
everybody has a similar looking code.
Documentation,
if there's a change to code which
requires to be noted in the architecture,
it should be noted.
There should be architectural reviews
periodically.
In fact,
if you're working on something like Scrum.
The architect,
if the architect is a very senior person,
at least the architect's representative
should try to be present in the scrumps.
Or maybe it should be a part of the team.
Sometimes the product owner
We have a good architectural exposure.
You have the Scrum Master.
The Scrum Master is supposed to
facilitate.
The team works with a lot of independents.
But the customer's requirement are
handled by the product owner.
So product owner should be very well
aware of the architecture to make sure
that you don't divert off from
conformance.
if you don't have an architect
specifically assigned to the project.
So, in every in Scrum.
At the end of every architect,
every iteration,
you have a product that is deliverable.
It can be delivered.
It may not be delivered,
but it should be ready for delivery.
An iteration signifies a complete product.
It cannot be that at the end of an
iteration, you never say,
we are working on this.
We have completed this.
And only what is completed becomes a part
of the...
a backlog. When you create a backlog,
you create a unit of items which together
can be delivered, can be delivered.
So that way you have to be.
Very clear about.
the concept of a backlog in a scrum type
of environment.
And the product owner is supposed to be
available all the time and is capable of
answering any questions that the
developers may require anytime.
You don't have to wait for.
A review to be able to see us come.
To see an exercise.
Any, any comments, any?
Contributions to.
Drift.
If not, less more.
So.
Whenever there are new team members.
They should be brought up to date with
architecture.
so that they don't become the reason for
drift.
They may not be have been working on the
project.
You may not bring them into the detail,
but the architecture should be clearly
explained to them.
Code should be periodically reviewed.
You're going to be a group review,
you're going to architectural review.
If you're separating.
the entire application into different
subsystems.
Clean packages.
Loaded.
You're taking me to a totally different
theme, you know.
For a good part of my life,
I've given a lot of my time to an
institution called the Rotary Club.
And the Rotary Club,
if you go about it very religiously,
it has got a number of saints working
there.
There are people who are really gem of a
person.
And every procedure in Rotary is
documented.
They've got an enormous documentation.
And you want to conduct a meeting,
what's supposed to be done?
You want to do sense of function,
what's supposed to be done?
What a club is allowed to do?
What a club is not allowed to do?
What the role of every director is?
Everything is documented.
Everything is known,
and the people who have been in Rotary
for 10, 15 years,
they have read a lot of them,
attended training programs, and...
Rotary is supposed to be a very saintly
organization. They do a lot of good.
If they have parties,
they do it with their own money.
And they make sure their money left aside
for social work.
They get together and help each other in
business,
but they also help the community by
making the community better.
Similarly, this whole thing about Scrum,
the role of a product owner,
the Scrum Master, team members.
It is a very holy system.
And the product owner is supposed to be
dedicated to the project in which...
He or she belongs.
Well, as Krishna has pointed out,
it's not very often the truth,
because these are normally important
people,
people with a lot of clout within the
organization,
they know the work thoroughly.
And...
There is an old dictum.
If you want to get a job done,
go to a busy man.
And all the work gets dumped on these
busy people, and they become busier.
It's unfortunate that if they are not
available, then...
Really the job of a product owner as per.
recorded in agile methodologies is not
being executed by the product owner.
Product owner is supposed to be available
on a continuous basis for clarification.
Supposed to be the one person who knows
the product inside out and is in a
position to speak on behalf of all
stakeholders.
as to what should be done,
has understood the requirements from the
stakeholders very thoroughly and in
complete sync with the architect on the
decisions taken to be executed.
So, well, that's the truth, then.
Yes,
practice often deviates from the truth.
Okay, just go on architecture and testing.
How does architecture help in testing
activity?
Since the architecture is known.
The testers know what to test.
Since the ASRs are known.
Measurable.
Yardsticks have been placed.
They can help to create integration tests.
The architects can be involved.
An architect,
if the testers were involved at the right
time at the time of designing the
architecture,
and it was known that a lot of testing
will be required when this application is
live,
testability could have been prioritized
as an ESR.
So we have one eye into the session.
We take about a 10 minutes break,
and we'll be back after the break.
Okay.
So is there, there's no query.
We continue with the class as usual.
So, they help us.
Right, test test cases.
Because we know what are the priorities
in ESRs,
whatever is the priority in development
is the priority in testing.
So if something was important as a
requirement, we need to.
Verify, validate, make sure that.
We are being able to provide it correctly.
We had the utility tree.
We have given it a lot of importance in
this course.
We identify what are the high priority.
As far as business value is concerned,
high priority on architectural impact,
and that automatically becomes high
priority in test cases.
No.
What about an integrated test plan?
When you test,
you've got a modular structure.
Within a module.
Testing, verification,
validation has been done by the
individual teams.
When we have an integration,
we know exactly what interaction the
architect has.
told us that this is the type of
interaction between modules that should
be possible.
All those use cases need to be tested out.
Any dependency,
modules can either have an interaction or
they can have a dependency.
One module uses another module.
Whether all the purposes,
including the boundary values,
regression testing,
every type of testing can be done in the
body.
Then.
You can.
Identify which modules need to be subject
to what level of testing.
Now,
there are various distributed
requirements which the architecture may
tell us. The architect will tell us that..
.
You should be able to...
Use various type of database just by
changing the connection time.
You from SQL DB, you change to ODBC,
and with ODBC you should be able to
perform the same activity by having the
data maybe in access.
So,
you may need to come do a complete
regression test with different data
sources.
That if rollback is to be permitted.
rollback which is cascaded over multiple
devices or multiple subsystems.
You may like to check that out.
You may like to test whether you'll be
able to hot swap.
Census.
Swap a payment gateway.
Choose between multiple payment gateways
that you may have done some customized
coding depending on the facilities
available or a particular payment gateway.
If you want to change the payment gateway,
whether one of the requirements was that
without much downtime,
you should be able to change the payment
gateway. So.
Maybe for that purpose, you might have to,
the architect may have decided that we'll
have an adapter.
So,
all our communication with the adapter,
the adapter will communicate with the
payment gateway.
So that...
We can.
Maybe later, create.
A factory, a factory pattern, where?
On a common protocol, you can generate.
an abstraction for a particular payment
gateway and get connected there.
So.
If there's anybody sharing anything on
testing, most welcome.
This is a topic which I hopped on right
in the beginning.
where I clarified to the people present
as to what we mean by reconstruction.
At the expense of sounding repetitive,
I would like to...
Repeat again: reconstruction is not is
not the development of a new architecture.
It is not changing from an existing
architecture to a new architecture that
is not reconstruction.
That is modification.
Reconstruction of our architecture is.
Determining the architecture from a
running system and presenting it,
documenting it.
making views for it,
that is architectural reconstruction.
The various techniques.
available, whereby you can do it.
We'll discuss some of the techniques.
There are various tools that are
available.
We'll mention some of the tools.
I'm sure some of you would have used
certain tools.
Is there anybody here who's used any
reconstruction tool?
Okay, no volunteers at least.
I'm sure people have used these tools.
Maybe when they see it,
they will remember.
OK, OK, I have not used it.
Cloud code will reconstruct the code or
reconstruct the architecture.
I'm ready.
Share something about Claude and Kiru
with us.
Hello, yes, sir, am I audible?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah,
so I have a past experience using Claude
code to, you know,
let's say if we have a new project or
there is a legacy system on there which
has not been documented properly.
I have tried using Claude code to get out
different kind of views related to.
Okay.
The folder, and we can check and test.
Need, like me.
What is the input that you give to Claude?
Input is you can create a prompt or
depending upon what you want to get out
of it. Like,
let's say if you want to analyze how the
model new controller framework has been
used in the project.
So it will just scan through the project
and give you a dynamic representation or
it can also explain it to you in.
Ring English.
So,
you you need you need to have the source
code available.
Yes, yes, definitely.
Source code of any context in terms of
Okay, so ffe.
technical documentation plus the code
would help.
Can it, can it, can it,
can it pick it up from the executables?
I haven't tried that, not sure.
Okay, okay,
maybe it'll be able to do something.
Sonar Cube, of course,
is a very popular tool.
What about Kiro?
Hero is more of a spec-driven development
tool,
so it can be used to create documentation
as well,
so it is one of the similar ones like we
use.
Okay.
Again, starting from source code.
Use this.
Okay.
So, URMILA,
share some experience of SUNITA Tube,
whatever you are aware of.
So, sir, it's more of code quality.
It checks the code quality,
like whenever we before the C.A.C.D.
runs and all we run this code quality for
the with the sonar cube.
OK, OK,
so it's a beautiful tool and it's a very
popular tool for.
Is it open source by any chance?
I think it is.
This will not cook.
I think this was.
Is Sonar Cube an open source tool?
I'm checking shirts.
Yes,
it is offered a free and open source
edition called the SUBBANNAVAR Cube
Community Build Edition. However,
if you are referring to...
Yeah.
Chicken.
It offers a free and open source edition.
So it is one of those dual licensing
policies where they have a community
built edition and then you can have a
paid edition also.
Many tools are like that.
One of the very popular tools used by
almost anybody in IT is
The Git GitHub.
Git, of course, is open source,
but GitHub is a Microsoft tool.
They have a free version and they have a
paid version.
Okay, very good, very good.
That is a good thing. So,
Sundar has used Cloud Code to understand
the system.
The.
how it has been built and to achieve some
quality attributes for assignment one.
Good.
See, in today's world,
if you're not using these tools.
This is like having two hands,
you tie them at the back and you start
moving around.
So.
There's absolutely no reason not to use
the tools.
It's a nowadays the argument is becoming
even more peculiar.
Then, lots of activity.
which we know how to do. For example,
take a very...
something which I've been doing for years
and that is linear regression or curve
fitting. You have a lot of points.
And if it's linear,
you try to find the best fit curve.
And people who learn paths with B,
we know how to calculate it.
We'll draw a table, we'll find X, x ^2,
y ^2, we'll find out XY,
and we'll find out the best fit line in
the form of Y is equal to M x + c.
And we'll not only find out the best fit
line,
we'll find out the regression coefficient
R.
Today, you don't require to do that.
Even a tool like Excel,
you give it the data points.
And it gives you the equation as well as
the regression coefficient.
And any programming language worth its
sort will have functions like slope,
intercept.
and you give the X data points,
Y data points,
and in some languages you give them as
pairs. Same here, and you'll get the line.
Now,
whether we people trying to understand
the meaning of Y is equal to MX plus C
and knowing the algorithms,
we are making a mistake or not.
And today...
When you are teaching or you are
expecting students?
to use tools.
whether it is fair to make sure that they
understood the basic mathematical
construction which they were built.
Maybe that role is too specialized.
We are supposed to leave it for
mathematicians.
Because if you try to learn all that,
you will have a complete knowledge of all
the tools that are required.
So.
Okay.
Sundar, we know service discovery,
but why didn't you learn?
How come you learnt about service
discovery by using dot code?
Does hear you out?
So that I'm sharing.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you.
Great. So
The assignment that I did was to
understand how our system handles the
bulk processing of our data by our
customers.
So I got to know that there is a message
queue that we use and there are multiple
Okay.
Right.
brokers so that we can.
have to satisfy the scalability and
availability.
So there were multiple brokers that are
there.
Okay.
Some are active and some are passive.
So there is a service discovery that they
Okay.
use to
understand the IP addresses of those
brokers to get the IP addresses and then
Okay, got it. Okay.
send the message to them.
Oh,
since you subject the code to the cloud
code,
it told you that there's a service
discovery network that you're using.
Oh, you're using? OK, great, great. So,
it gave you a break up.
You came to do that there were multiple
brokers,
you came to know that there's service
discovery,
you do that the service discovery would
get across to them. Great, great.
So this is exactly what one needs to do
while reconstructing an architecture.
So at least people who,
if you have used this,
you know very clearly what the
distinguish between, distinguish,
what's the distinguishing feature between
reconstruction,
reconstruction and modification.
Now,
you need to reconstruct to be able to
modify. That's another matter.
Because once you reconstruct,
you know what is going on. So...
You are not putting your hand into the
pan without knowing what is happening
inside.
Thanks for your participation. Yeah.
So...
to identify components and the
relationship.
And that's exactly the example you have
given us.
You came to know about the components and
the relationships by using the story.
Agreed components into abstract
components.
Specific grouping to tools,
so you come to know.
OK, service broker. OK,
so you can make it an abstract component
and say anyone can be used,
analyze the architecture.
So...
You can get an idea of the overall
architecture.
From source code.
From executable. Executable also,
there are two types of executables.
Executables for debug,
they contain much more information.
In fact,
you can reverse engineer and even get the
source code.
from an executable if it is a executable
under debug mode.
And if it is a.
Final production run executable,
you still.
You can trace it and find out the
execution paths. And from that,
you can come to know about architecture.
And of course,
today there are tools which will do this
for you and graphically depict it.
The build script, the build script.
which you may be using, like,
we had URMILA here,
who is working on a CICD pipeline.
They have build scripts,
and the build scripts itself gives you
how the build is taking place,
so you come to know the components,
so you get a hint about the architecture
from there.
If you have some documentation,
you will know about the classes.
By through studying the input outputs,
you'll come to know which files are being
used. And if you trace the working,
you'll come to know when they are getting
updated, how they're getting updated.
You may come to know about collar-collee
relationships.
Again,
if the documentations are available,
or you try to trace, and...
If you have a global data access,
if you have data stores.
what type of data store you use.
If you know the type of data store used
from that itself,
you get an idea of what the architect had
in mind.
You may be using Hadoop, NoSQL,
you were using MongoDB,
you may be using Oracle, so...
Invariably,
when you know what components are being
used,
you get an idea of what the architect may
be thinking about. So here are your files,
directories, functions.
So, you come to extract the elements, and.
..
To come,
you see the relationship that these
elements have with another element.
This file we include this file,
and where do you get see hash include?
From here, you come to know.
that these files are being used if you
have the source code.
And if you have files,
you can assume that they must be getting
used somewhere else.
So particularly while building,
you will come to know that these DLLs
have been used.
If you have files,
the functions which are defined in a file,
if the files are available, variables,
you control variables, directories.
Directories, relations,
the file functions with functions,
functions with variables.
So all these type of relationships have
their own stories to tell it for you to
figure out the stories and you,
if you have tools, you can.
So this is the execution trace.
How do?
The caller-call relationships,
so based on the caller-call relationship
by running a program and...
Getting a trace, you can find out.
The.
Component and connection relationships
and present it.
Army is a tool.
Which gives you a view of...
The.
Systems activity and.
This activity gives you a relationship
between components from which you can try
to determine the architecture of the
system.
Vanish system will identify spots of
interaction.
And once you have understood that these
are aggregates of components which
interact with one another.
The quantum of interaction gets mapped.
And with this interaction,
you can try to figure out what may be
happening,
what type of component connection
relationship may be existing.
We are talking about a system which is
running for years, maybe 10 years,
20 years, 25 years,
and you've got no document,
no papers available.
There are no employees available who are
involved in the development.
Only you've got users.
So if you can trace the through.
A system like this,
you can determine the spots.
See, from here you.
You analyze and you find that it is not
cleared.
So that.
That is Sonar, Sonar J.
Structure One Zero One, Dally,
and of course our friends have told us
about plot code. Nowadays,
it looks like plotting is a mood to do
everything for us.
They want us to forget everything else.
In fact,
you want to prepare a PowerPoint
presentation,
you want to prepare an Excel sheet.
You want to prepare some programs,
you want to write a workflow.
probably the best place to...
The spend learning is now claude.
And.
In fact, it's not a question of learning,
Claude.
If you're not learning it.
You're probably planning to retire.
It's almost like that. But of course,
not to say that Claude is the only option.
If your work gets done with any one of
the large language models,
it's good enough for you.
There's nobody is not using it, like,
as I told you, in BITS,
the question papers are being set using.
a tool which takes inputs as books,
it takes slides,
and it prepares question papers,
answer papers,
and also the evaluation guide.
So that's the level.
The next level will be when your answer
paper is going to get evaluated by the
system.
So, already work would be on,
and maybe the people you recommend for
this course after you,
they might get the results the very next
day, because...
When automation was not as great.
When the only machine available in the
institute was that IBM 1130 and it was
one of the three institutions in the
country having it, then I passed out.
After the comprehensive exam.
On the 14th day, we always got a result,
always, so...
We used to normally have a 15 days break
in winters between the two semesters.
And within those 15 days,
we not only got the result,
we went and registered for the next
semester based on our previous results.
So
Today.
If paper setting.
is automatically making sure the quality
of question papers are better,
better coverage.
more correctness and with proper answer
keys.
And students tell us why can't we see one
of the answer keys?
So I normally tell students just.
If you're using Claude, use Claude,
but even Gemini works beautifully.
Your version of Gemini,
you are allowed with bits is an education
level version.
And it will give you beautiful answers
and it will give you an evaluation guide
also that this type of question,
how is it likely to be evaluated? So,
and I have been suggesting to students
that you should upload your slides and
ask HEMRAJ to give you some questions,
sample questions with answers.
That's the best way to prepare.
And the last thing you should look at is
the previous year's question paper,
because that is only an indication of the
type of question that will definitely not
come.
So it doesn't help you to exclude 3
questions from your life.
Already,
we've got examples how we went about it,
tools that he used.
So...
You had.
With the little villa, and...
Sundar Sharan telling us how they've used
it.
If there's any other experience sharing,
most welcome.
Does anybody use Alvin out there?
So here you got a whole few pages which
you can look at.
When you start with software architecture
reconstruction,
go to understand the goals, processes,
inputs, techniques, and outputs. Goals.
Look at related artifacts.
And let me enlarge it a little bit.
You may be wanting to.
do a reconstruction to be able to
document.
to be able to reuse it somewhere else,
the same architecture as it is,
to assure conformance.
If any changes that are made,
you want to make sure you're conforming
to the old architecture.
So conformance could be an objective.
Co-evolution,
which means along with what is running,
you want to...
Evolve other modules or other systems
which and conformity with this one.
Analyze the performance.
If you understand the architecture,
what was being achieved, what are the,
you'll be able to set benchmarks as to.
Why a particular design was used, and...
Evolution is just like co-evolution,
you want to.
Now change the system and try to bring up
something better.
Want to study the processes?
You can take a bottom-up, top-down,
or a hybrid view,
depending on what is available to you.
So when you go top down,
you try to understand the overall
architecture, the subsystems involved,
go into each subsystem,
break it up into modules, go into modules.
If all this source code is available and
you want to go to that depth,
you can go right down to...
Understanding individual classes, methods,
variables.
And in the bottom-up.
You can deposit your code.
It goes to the code to try to determine.
what functionality that code performs.
In a given class,
where is the classes used,
how it is interacting with other classes?
From that, you will come to the modules,
identify individual subsystems,
and then build up to the...
Top get the overall architecture and
hybrid would be a mixture of both
approaches, inputs.
The inputs could be not architectural,
it could be architectural.
Non-architecture.
Source code will be there,
text documentation may be available.
Dynamic information that is traces how
the program runs, operation guides,
physical organization, where,
what are the machines available?
You've got clients, you've got servers,
what type of servers,
what type of storage devices,
what type of networking devices,
human organization,
who are the people who operate the system?
for the people who maintain it.
The moment you know who are the people
involved,
you know what information you can get
from them.
The people operating can tell you how
they go about the work they do.
That itself will give you a lot of ideas.
People maintaining the system,
replacing hardware components,
we at least come to know what hardware
components are there.
Historical information changes made in
the past.
Any operation documents from the.
past. Human expertise,
people who worked on the system,
maybe programmers who worked on it once a
time,
or people who were in the company when it
was developed,
or third parties who know about similar
systems may be able to help you.
And architectural input,
what type of styles have been followed?
What are the viewpoints?
Is there any frameworks,
known frameworks that have been used?
Techniques.
You will be using quasi means.
Ohh.
Not quite manual.
But almost like venues,
that means you trigger it and then it's
automatic. And quasi-automatic is...
Almost automatic, but maybe...
And semi-automatic means,
so all these things.
Slight variations of semi-quasis,
not quite, that is quasi.
So quasi-manual Ruby, construction,
exploration,
these are the techniques you may use to
try to reconstruct the architecture.
In quasi-automatic use concepts,
clustering, dominance, metrics.
These are the techniques you will use to
try to tabulate to whatever work is being
done and abstraction.
relational queries, logical queries,
programs, lexical queries.
If these are available to you,
you can find out the architecture from
these. And by investigation,
this is abstraction,
investigation is recognized as pattern,
graphic patterns,
State engine maps,
if any of these things can be drawn,
and you will come to have a better idea
of the architecture.
Outputs.
Could be a visual output,
which means you may draw a component
connector diagram,
you will draw a module structure.
The complete architecture architectural
document,
the way we indexed it in one of the
previous chapters, you can write a book.
Analysis.
would be an understanding of the system,
how it performs,
and conformance can be horizontal or
vertical.
What's the difference between vertical
and horizontal conformance?
Vertical is,
as we move through the system.
Top level to bottom level,
whether they all conform or not,
or horizontal is.
Try to make sure that in a given level of
working,
you're conforming to the exact guidance
that the architecture had given.
For example,
you're working just at the data access
layer. Data access layer itself,
whether the input output
taken is as per the specification.
There is a computation method,
where is the logging method.
All these are conforming to the
architecture statement or not.
So this could be the type of
You start with raw view extraction.
You try to pick up information.
Collate as much data as you can.
You pick up source code,
take the execution phrases,
get the scripts, find all the files.
What are the relations?
Anything that you can pick up,
just put it together.
So this we call raw view extraction.
Then database construction.
if you have access to the database.
Database can give you a lot of idea on
how the...
Again.
Depends on how well the database is
organized.
Practically, you sometimes find that.
Lots of useless tables will be lying
around in the database.
That can be a sort of problem if the
database is maintained clean.
It really can give you a very good idea
then.
Sometimes some of these architectural...
The tools like Ms. SQL and Oracle,
they've got.
Diagramming capability within the tool,
which means your.
relationships are diagrammatically
available within the tool itself.
They give you a lot of ideas to the
interrelationship of data elements.
Then you have something called view
fusion.
You?
get some views of your modules,
how they're working,
and then you see the data.
Mind you, the database.
In a way,
if a person understands a database ER
diagrams and you understand object
relationship diagrams from an
object-oriented programming,
you'll find that the mapping is very
similar and the mapping of a database.
reflects in the implementation of a
program, the way the data is collected,
the way it is stored,
the way it is processed.
So if you have a combination of expertise
from the development team and the
database team,
they can fuse the views which are
available.
In ear diagrams and object relationship
diagrams, and try to understand what...
the real setup is all about.
Then your architectural analysis,
validate the correctness of architectural
elements.
Via view fusion,
this could be a restriction that a layer
calls objects in an adjacent layer,
or all DB access should be via an entity
bean only, so...
You look into the system and try to find
out whether there are any constraints
that have been imposed of this kind, and..
.
That itself gives you an idea of the and
iterate once you've got this analysis
again, pick up raw data,
keep rejecting data.
So, here is a scenario.
Will you get a view?
On how messages are being bust?
You have a nodal diagram.
This graph represents a trees.
between various elements,
how data moves between various elements.
And.
This is a.
Execution path.
So.
So that you can...
Go through the execution part and see
whether there are any issues that can be
observed. It will track the...
Haku.
To reverse engineer DB schema,
it helps in creating your diagrams from
existing DBs. OK, superb.
So.
In fact, reverse engineering,
wherever it is possible,
is a great way to get the source code
detail, and
Infect.
Long back once we re-engineered,
reverse engineered a code and realized
how fragile code can really be.
How easy it is to break code,
so I call it, as the name applies.
Very good too for a hacker.
And if you can hack an executable.
In the.
Old days, you know what we used to do?
We used to hack an executable and make
sure to make it run by bypassing the
password. So in an assembly language.
There are commands like GNZ,
jump if not zero.
J is at jump of zero so
In the machine language code,
you had the assemblers where against the
machine language,
you could see the assembly language.
So in the beginning of the code,
you look for all the JZs or JNZs and just
reverse it. Instead of JNZ, make it JZ.
And sometimes, you know,
the program will run through because...
When you're checking the password.
If...
Something is true, you're supposed to run;
if not, you're not supposed to run. So,
just by changing it, if it is not true,
it'll run. So,
things were as simple as that. Today,
it is not possible to break code as
easily as that, because...
Life has moved on and things have become
more stringent.
Group extraction components, so.
Okay, you're an electricity engineer.
The dish.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Okay, okay, same here.
So we've studied some of the same stuff,
but only problem is when we studied
electronics,
there was nothing called computer science.
So half the people studying electronics
were doing it with the objective of
getting a job in computers. So
Almost the entire batch would be working
on software somewhere, or maybe hardware.
But those days, you know,
an engineer was supposed,
expected to work on things like assembly
language.
We normally used to read the software to
maths graduates or physics graduates.
So as an electronic engineer,
you came up from the assembly language
path.
So, assembly language, Fortran,
whereas the maths people went in for
languages like COBOL.
Of course, to survive on a job,
one had to learn COBOL.
And most of the money seemed to have been
in my lifetime in the commercial
applications. So one had to,
and lucky for me,
since I had a management degree, and
Had made it in finance, so...
Life worked out fairly good.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
So.
Of course, nowadays, you know,
machine language coding is also become
quite different. Most of the time,
even embedded software,
you will use code in C and then create
the, and then burn it into a ROM.
So,
very little coding is currently being
really done in core assembly.
What about you, PRABHU?
She must have written the program in...
Object C or something.
Or MPMC this in the subject of yours.
Yes, during in college.
Object C.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Object C,
and we would also write these commands
and then actually it was during the COVID
time,
Mm.
so we would run it through the 8086
processor simulator,
if you remember those old 8085. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
We spend most of our time with 8085.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so you would...
So 8086 is 8086 is mostly with the IBM PC,
fairly useless stuff. 8086,
very powerful but useless.
Like design-wise, never been a favorite.
But once they moved on to 80286,
it became something good.
You are at 02863
Yes,
but my friends who are in like for
electronics and stuff,
they're using embedded C throughout,
Yeah.
like who are in automotive or some other
industries.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
and that's how it is,
but way back we had to actually write an
assembly, and then it moved on.
C has been there for a long time,
so it was C assembly.
You would write some parts in assembly,
some in C.
Then you'll burn it together, and...
You know, from assembly to machine,
you had to sometimes write your own
cross-assemblers.
So you would write your assembly and
convert to machine language and burn the
ROM. And later on,
when the PC became popular,
you started getting a card for the PC
where you could burn the ROM directly
from a PC.
Anyway, now things are,
and you got the kids nowadays,
Oh.
Yeah.
nowadays you got kids. OK,
so this is where analysis is concerned.
View Fusion using Sonar.
So, Willa,
you would like to tell us something about
this?
Is she there?
Will you?
Yes, and in our electronics,
we take a project, right?
Yes.
We used to do this.
So we had a program written in some
Mm.
simulator and then we burned that in the
microcontroller 8086.
So we created something called a burglar
alarm sort of thing.
Okay, okay.
Right, or no, that's a ported long back,
but still remember,
Okay, great.
and that time we used to burn it using
the parallel port,
Yeah.
not the serial USB port,
but the parallel port from our PC.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, you have to use it.
But eventually,
I think in your generation also,
you must be getting the development kits,
which you could connect over the port and
you had a separate,
I bought one machine once.
I did some work,
I've forgotten the name of the machine.
It was.
But maybe I, I do know if you,
I do know like it,
Probably, yeah, yeah, I think that, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes.
it is a combined package.
Yeah, Ardino, Uno, Ardino, Nano,
those kind of names will be there.
Okay.
No, I didn't know. Yeah, right.
So we started using this kits,
but this was way up in life,
like for me at least. For you,
it would have been the beginning of your..
.
Period of working, so, URMILA,
you will tell us something about the view
fusion.
So not, so not it should be cube, yeah.
SARITA.
Yeah,
I think it is more of like combining
different views. Like, I mean,
we'll have the source code view and
deployment view, all this view,
it'll combine and it'll generate.
A few of the views that you require for
which you can use for presenting your
G.
architecture.
Yes.
So,
here we have taken a case of vertical
slice and horizontal slice,
indicating the dimension.
So, here you got your say your controller,
data domain, DSI services,
and particularly you've got your...
contract, customer, distributor requests,
so various aspects.
So you can have horizontal and vertical
divisions and try to.
get various views, put them together.
We are, again, we are not going to,
as a part of this course,
you are not supposed to be able to use
any of these tools.
We are not doing anything practically.
But be aware of it so that if you are
using it,
at least you heard about these things.
So, you do an analysis,
check the conform conformance to
architecture,
whether you're doing any modifications.
Violence of architecture can be detected
by sonar cube if you.
Do some work, present it again.
Example of architecture violation
directed by SUBBANNAVAR,
just a few pages given for you to see,
and that.
ends your course for the midterm exam.
My best wishes to you.
And.
As I said,
I'm really not bothered about the exam.
I'm really concerned that whatever you
got in the eight sessions,
go through the slides and make sure.
that your vocabulary in speaking within
an IT company is enriched by virtue of
having gone through these parts.
Particularly whether or not you use them
for the exams,
understand all the tactics that have been
mentioned in the slides.
So other things you'll remember,
tactics are some things which you need to
Look up.
Yep.
Okay,
then I switch off the recording and I'll
say bye to you.
Thank you, sir. Bye.
Thank you. Thank you. Bye, bye, bye.